by realizing that control is just fear
the reason you're controlling is because
you're scared of if somebody else does
it it doesn't go as well because you're
scared if something fails that people
will judge control is just a long-winded
whining road to the fear of judgment
when that's the question the biggest
thing to think about is actually failing
on purpose just to taste it a lot of
[__] I do pushes me out of comfort where
I know there'll be failures along with
it I still like practicing the flavor of
failure there's not a human being I'm
looking at right now that hasn't made
mistakes has it had missteps I've made a
million of them you got to get
comfortable with losing this is the
whole eighth place trophy thing that I'm
[__] passionate about we're making
kids scared of losing we're telling them
and it's bad to lose that's why you get
a trophy it's good to lose you need to
lose and see the disappointment and
those people that look up to you to then
understand that it's not that scary